évidemment nous avons quelques vestiges
archéologiques de l'agriculture avec
quelques vignes plus symbolique que
réelle
non les hauts-de-seine ce n'est pas une
terre agricole il faut le dire
loyalement
c'est même le plus petit département de
france qu'on ne sait pas toujours
on produit du vin à suresnes on produit
aussi un peu de vin à bagneux
il ya quelques vestiges comme ça mais
c'est plutôt de manière folklorique
on n'a pas de prétention agricole les
yvelines dont près de la moitié de leur
territoire en agriculture et si vous
comptez la forêt car la forêt viennoise
est très importante et c'est une
ressource naturelle qui aura de plus en
plus d'importance à l'avenir puisque
nous comptons développer la construction
par le bois et l'énergie par le bois est
bien plus des deux tiers du département
des yvelines sont des espaces naturels
donc c'est non seulement un art de vivre
une qualité de vie mais c'est aussi une
dimension économique considérable
ça représente des centaines pardon des
milliers d'emplois donc c'est important
mais c'est surtout imaginons si nous
n'avions pas les agriculteurs
si nous n'avions pas les exploitants
de forêt nous aurions obligé nous
puissance publique d'entretenir ces
espaces donc ça nous coûteraient des
sommes folles
nous avons la chance d'avoir à la fois
des activités économiques créatrices de
richesses mais aussi ses activités
économiques créatrices de richesses sont
des activités d'intérêt général
puisqu'elle nous permettent de
bénéficier de paysages admirable se
promener dans les yvelines le week-end
après une dure semaine de travail qu'est
ce qu'il y a de mieux
ce sont des marchés potentiels
considérables puisque il y a autant
d'élèves scolarisés dans les collèges du
département des hauts-de-seine que des
yvelines et nous avons l'ambition de
développer les circuits courts les
circuits courts c'est-à-dire la
production de légumes
la production de viande sur les
territoires où ils sont consommés et
comme dans les hauts-de-seine ils ne
peuvent pas produire parce qu'il n'y a
pas d' espaces agricoles
ils sont tout à fait disposés à
consommer les produits des agriculteurs
yvelinois et j'ajouterai que nous avons
aussi sur nos territoires et en
particulier dans les hauts-de-seine des
entreprises qui ont des restaurants
d'entreprise qui vont se convertir aussi
à ses circuits courts donc il y a la
possibilité d'accompagner la mutation
inéluctable de l'agriculture
francilienne qui était très exportatrice
de céréales autrefois qui essaye de le
rester mais qui a de grandes difficultés
face à la concurrence internationale en
particulier de l'ukraine et de
l'argentine est donc trouver des
débouchés à proximité c'est à la fois
pour le consommateur un gage de qualité
et pour l'agriculteur un gage de revenus
un accord gagnant-gagnant en quelque
sorte ça nous permet d'avoir des
produits frais des produits même sur
commande adaptée à nos besoins notre
demande et donc il ya une profonde
complémentarité nous avons plutôt des
entreprises d'agroalimentaire dans les
hauts-de-seine mais nous n'avons pas de
production agricole naturellement et ne
nous sommes malheureux dans les
hauts-de-seine d'être si urbanisées
d'être si dense et quand on va dans les
yvelines
on a grâce aux relations que nous avons
le sentiment aussi d'être chez nous et
c'est un autre univers
vous savez malheureusement depuis qu'on
a eu on est dans des territoires si
dense où on ne plante plus grand chose
on en est à l'agriculture urbaine c'est
à dire que on plante des arbres sur les
toits vous voyez ou à quelle folie on en
arrive c'est paris qui nous a évidemment
contaminé avec cette folie dans les
yvelines nous avons totalement
sacraliser les terres agricoles et en
particulier nous avons donc créé un
organisme qui s'appelle bio dif et cet
organisme biodisque consiste à compenser
chaque fois qu'il ya un projet
urbanistique en créant de nouveaux
espaces agricoles donc non seulement
nous ne voulons pas les consommer mais
nous voulons en ré ouvrir et c'est un
travail qui est complètement
contemporain cette idée selon laquelle
la terre agricole et quelque chose d'un
fini c'est une idée du passé
aujourd'hui nous savons que
la rareté de nos ressources doit être
infiniment préserver et on s'inscrit
totalement dans cette dynamique